just to recap this and then I want to
bring in our guest New Jersey the
lawyers are challenging the
constitutionality of the professional
and amateur sports Protection Act and
this was implemented in 1992 made
gambling on pro and collegiate athletics
illegal in all but Nevada Delaware
Montana and Oregon so those four states
had legalized sports gambling at the
time so they were grandfathered in New
Jersey is arguing the interpretations of
the Tenth Amendment will make it illegal
for the federal government to force
certain states to adhere to regulations
while exempting others so that that's
the situation that we have Daniel
Wallick is a gaming and sports attorney
kind enough to join us on short notice
Daniel thanks good morning why the delay
by the Supreme Court we thought maybe
there was gonna be a ruling tomorrow or
yesterday well just like you know any
fine wine no wine before its time the
Supreme Court has had a number of cases
under consideration in this case was
only argued three months ago I think
many people jump the gun yesterday in
anticipating a ruling but the average
time frame for a decision from the date
of oral argument and the argument was in
early December is three plus months but
we're going to get a divided ruling from
the Supreme Court I was in the courtroom
that day and I could tell that there
were some judges on both sides of the
issue and I would expect dissenting
opinions concurring opinions and we're
talking about an important question of
constitutional law so I believe that
this one is going to take a little
longer than average and we could be
looking at April May and potentially the
last week of June so this is not out of
the ordinary it would have been it would
have been a surprise to me had the court
reached its ruling at the three month
mark best guess what happens most likely
scenario is the court will declare this
federal law to be unconstitutional
because it violates states rights under
the Tenth Amendment most of the justices
that day seemed to be skeptical that
that Congress had the ability to tell
States how to regulate its own citizens
unless they set forth unless Congress
sets forth its own regulatory scheme and
that didn't happen here with past but
is just an outright prohibition and a
number the justices were skeptical that
that kind of a law would pass muster
under the Tenth Amendment so I would
expect this federal law to become
invalidated as a result of the court's
opinion whether it's April May or June
when that happens there are at least a
dozen states that already have bills
introduced in their legislative sessions
to legalize sports betting so the way I
see this playing out is we could have
legal sports betting in as many as 10 to
12 states by the beginning of the 2018
NFL season however there is also a
possibility that the court could side
with New Jersey and and find that New
Jersey's attempt to legalize sports
betting does not violate pass pas and
otherwise leave pass pas intact as a
good law so there are two possible
outcomes in which New Jersey could win
if it's unconstitutional every state
that wants sports betting can have it if
New Jersey wins on these narrow
statutory grounds it's likely that New
Jersey will have a monopoly for the time
being and then the issue will get punted
over to Congress Daniel thank you for
joining us we'll check in with you no
matter what the verdict is my pleasure
dan thanks for having me on
that's a Daniel Wallick he's a gaming
and Sports attorneys co-host of a
podcast called conduct detrimental for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show at
[Music]